digging for the truth is the name of the
game when it comes to True Detective but
here are some secrets to even the most
die-hard fans may not have uncovered yet
Matthew McConaughey took his role as one
of the leading stars and executive
producers of the first season of HBO's
True Detective seriously following
McConaughey's powerful performance in
2011's The Lincoln Lawyer Show creator
Nick pizzolato saw the potential for
McConaughey's involvement in the series
as the character rusting Cole acting
alongside Woody Harrelson and Michelle
Monaghan I mean it's like
your son just got your name on it like
like a bullet
running down the road coal is a complex
character who could easily alienate an
audience with his nihilism and apathy so
it was essential for McConaughey to
fully embody the Deep pain of this
character he arguably managed to do so
by extensively analyzing Cole's identity
to a fundamental level according to an
interview with rolling stone back in
2014 McConaughey explains his need to
create a document to chart his
character's life and growth over the
17-year timeline depicted in season one
he broke Carl's Essence down into four
stages 1995 crash 2002 and 2012. each
section contained its own lengthy
analysis of the character's State of
Mind at each time period the result was
a 450 page graph titled four stages of
resting coal it's common for many
television shows not to have full
multi-season arcs planned out from the
very beginning and as a result they can
lose direction True Detective didn't
have this problem as petsolato always
intended the show to be an anthology
with new casts and stories every season
much like Ryan Murphy and Brad falchuk's
Effect series American Horror Story the
strength of an anthology format comes
from creators exploring vastly different
stories while maintaining an overarching
theme and tone while the characters and
setting change each season follows the
same basic format two detectives
investigating crimes that lead to the
discovery of some wider conspiracy or
mystery the second season cast Colin
Farrell and Rachel McAdams as their duo
with the notable performance from Vince
Vaughn as a career criminal while the
third season of mahershala Ali and
Stephen Dorff however in an interview
with Entertainment Weekly pizzolato
claimed that he initially began writing
the story that eventually became season
3 as a new project only to realize that
it fit the themes of True Detective I
can understand your frustration with the
disease a disease you can even say what
it is
we can say what it almost certainly is
but the Anthology format doesn't sit
well with all fans with some messing the
chemistry between Harrison and
McConaughey and season 2 overall
receiving lukewarm critical and audience
receptions although most fans and
critics agree that season 3 was
something of a return to form no matter
how each season fares on their own Merit
the deliberate variation provides fresh
interest while preserving pizzolato's
dark atmospheric style it hasn't always
been smooth sailing for True Detective
while the first season was hailed as a
towering achievement of episodic
television the second and third season
struggled to live up to the hype but one
of the more troubling developments for
the show occurred during production of
the second season after the departure of
Kerry joji fukunaga the first season's
director the hole left by this major
change Force HBO and pizzolato to search
for other artists to direct episodes
throughout the next season and ended up
splitting the load between six different
directors which included Justin Lin
Daniel atias and Miguel so pochnik some
even bigger names were approached
earlier but for one reason or another
they declined the offer to Hellman
episode the biggest of these filmmakers
was horror icon David Cronenberg best
known for creating classic films such as
scanners the fly and video drone
according to vulture Cronenberg was
approached to direct but refused saying
I thought that the script was bad so I
didn't do it in TV the director is just
a traffic cop but on the other hand it
is work and there's a lot of it while
Pagan is a working relationship between
two actors such reportedly grown into a
deeply genuine friendship between
McConaughey and Harrelson the lead
actors and executive producers untrue
detective played two diametrically
opposing Partners who slowly grew to
understand respects and maybe even like
each other as historian fault this
combative relationship between raskol
and Marty heart was apparently difficult
for them to find when filming began
because of their existing relationship
yeah I didn't even know I'd hit him the
first time he was like yeah
good one yeah nice one yeah let me get
this True Detective was not the first
time these two actors work together with
them sharing screen time in the
lighthearted comedies Ed TV and Surfer
Dude according to USA Today McConaughey
and Harrison are to focus on breaking
their existing off-screen Dynamic so
that their characters could be
appropriately hostile to one another
Harrelson claimed not being on the same
wavelength a did what it was we were
doing but it was also uncomfortable
True Detective doesn't shy away from the
grimmest aspects of True Crime with
every season's underlying themes
encompassing almost another worldly evil
season 1 heavily references aspects of
occultism behind the murders of the
show's center with Creator Nick
pizzolato directly referencing horror
author Robert W Chambers book The King
in Yellow to create the series Eerie
atmosphere and plot some key terms and
phrases from this relatively obscure
piece of 19th century supernatural
horror are peppered throughout the first
season but the unknown killer raster
Marty hunts known as the yellow King who
lives in a dark place called cocosa
These are lifted directly from the novel
about the evil entity known as the king
and yellow as well as a lost city named
kakosa itself borrowed from an even
older short story by seminal American
Author Ambrose bears but Chambers was
also a strong admirer of HP Lovecraft so
his work was heavily infused with a
similar sense of cosmic dread this in
turn inspired pizzalazzo drawing a
series of element in an interview with
ew Peter Lardo directly addressed how
the horror elements of chamber book
James's writing process claiming when I
did that a kind of secondary language
began to form in the scripts where the
notion of cosmic horror became a very
real part of the environment While most
television shows and movies are filmed
and presented digitally these days some
notable exceptions continue to opt for
old school film acclaimed filmmakers
like Quentin Tarantino Martin Scorsese
and Christopher Nolan all the shoe
digital in favor of film according to an
interview with Cinema Blend Tarantino
claimed if you're not doing the work to
get a great shot then what's the point
digital cinematography puts all the
heavy work in the post-production rather
than planning and attempting to get the
perfect shot while on set fukunaga and
cinematographer Adam akapa chose to
shoot on 35 millimeter film for all
eight episodes of season one which made
it much more difficult to get some of
the more complex shots on the show
unfortunately it looks like this may
exclude the famous six minute tracking
shots in the episode who goes there
during an interview with variety aquapod
touched on the challenge of filming a
show this way he said in a film you
might be accustomed to shooting two to
three minutes of screen time a day on
True Detective we were shooting five to
six minutes every day basically your
time to devise prepare and execute your
workers cut in half many fans and
critics agree that the extra effort was
worth it but season 1's visual richness
being a big part of its overall appeal
sadly according to premium beat
subsequent Seasons weren't so lucky and
was shattered digitally
the second season of True Detective
brought in an entirely new cast of
characters in a completely different
location with arguably mixed results
while critics didn't seem to appreciate
the supposed decline in writing and
story they acknowledge the strong
leading performances of the many cops
and Crooks operating in Los Angeles this
includes Rachel McAdams as Annie
bezarides Vince Vaughn as Frank Simeon
and Taylor kitsch's Paul Woodrow but the
actors seemed to make the most waves
among the castles Colin Farrell as Ray
velcora a dirty cop torn between his
desire to do the right thing and his
criminal loyalties I remember you
dumping a body well reasons for all this
all that
I know exist for me
Farrell has had a long and eclectic
career playing a wide array of
characters in movies like in Rouge
Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them
and the Batman at the time he was added
to the True Detective cast he was most
often known for playing comedic Charming
Rogues but after being cast of the
alcoholic deadbeat detective throw that
to change his body to match according to
E.T the actor gained roughly 20 pounds
prior to filming and hated every second
of it Farrell claimed people think it
must be fun to eat what you want and it
is for the first day day two when you're
already on your second cheeseburger and
fries with a chocolate shake by 11AM not
so much
given the success of season 1 many
thought that pizzolato's writing and
fukunaga's directing were a match made
in heaven however the pair reportedly
didn't get along well during production
in the past few years fukunaga has gone
on record explaining how the working
partnership between him and pizzolato
deteriorated as the show went on during
an interview with The Hollywood Reporter
he claimed over the course of the
project Nick kept positioning himself as
if he was my boss and I was like but
you're not my boss we're Partners we
collaborate by the time they got to
post-production people like former HBO
programming President Michael Lombardo
were giving Nick more power it was
disheartening because it didn't feel
like the partnership was fair it seems
that this tension was one of the reasons
fukunaga did not return for season 2 or
3 of True Detective though he did retain
his role in credit as executive producer
some claim that one of the unsung heroes
of True Detective is actress Alexandra
Daddario as the character Lisa a court
stenographer and Marty Hart's mistress
in 1995. while Lee is from Marty's
secret affair becomes increasingly toxic
the Dario brings genuine empathy
complexity and death to a character who
easily could have been written off as
superficial go away I'll call the cop
s
however her character being highly
sexualized led to the Dario's
apprehension about filming her first
ever nude scenes for the show according
to a 2014 interview with MTV the actress
explains just how difficult it was to
prepare herself for her scene I really
wanted to be a part of the show and I
understood why the nudity and all of
that was required of the character the
character is really different from
anything that I've done before the
nudity was just part of that fortunately
Daddario claimed that the cast and crew
helped Porter at ease with house son in
particular making the whole interaction
very comfortable for her although it's
hard now to imagine Russ Cole played by
anyone else it turns out that the
casting was originally going to be
flipped with McConaughey slated to play
Marty Instead at this time McConaughey
was mainly known for his comedic roles
going all the way back to his
breakthrough role in Richard linklater's
Dazed and Confused while it already
branched further out with more serious
roles he was still seen as a jovial
performer who would fit better as the
more lighthearted Marty Heart during an
interview with WNYC in 2014 McConaughey
talked about his experience is being
brought in by HBO to read for Marty
Marley was intrigued by the show it was
actually Russ Cole's dialogue that
piqued his interest he said the guy I
can't wait to hear what comes out of his
mouth every time I turn the page as this
guy rusting Carl once McConaughey
realized how badly he wanted to play
Russ instead of Marty he apparently laid
it out to the show winners saying I read
the first two episodes and said look I
like the role of coal if you guys are
interested in me for the role I'm in he
was ultimately right considering his
performance and True Detective received
some of the highest praise he's ever
gone from audiences and critics
throughout his career
[Music]